Okay. I'm going to do two things
today, but I know I'm going to,
I know I'm going to do, I'm going to
end up talking about what I want to, um,
and that schools in the role
of schools in identity, but,
but uh,
uh,
first of all I want to talk a little
bit about the question of one and it's a
big historical debate, uh,
when, uh, people in, uh,
France began thinking of themselves as
French and then I'm going to specifically
look at the role of schools in that.
And I guess I've got to talk a little
bit about schools today too because you
know,
identity is something in an age of mass
tourism is a little hard to hold onto.
So, um, I think I'm going to talk
about that as well at the end.
I know, I know I am because
I love talking about it. Um,
and so I will be repeating just a
couple things that I said the first day,
but many of you were shopping or the
things the first day. Um, so the,
the sort of the podium antique or the,
or the question to be resolved is,
you know,
when do did people in France,
the majority of the population
or all the population, uh,
began thinking themselves as French as
opposed to as opposed to something else?
As I said, the first time,
uh, uh, that in 1789,
about half the population of France spoke
French in 1871 about a quarter of the
population, uh, spoke French. Um, and so,
um, it's, it's a leap of
faith to think that, uh,
that what the language you speak,
uh,
in totally informed your identity
or who you think you are. I mean,
I gave the case of Alsatians
who spoke, uh, a German who,
many of whom consider themselves
French after Alsace. And,
and much of the hand we're, we're,
uh, we're, uh, next, uh, uh,
to Germany in 1871.
Now,
there was a book published in
a long time ago, uh, uh, uh,
um, by a friend of mine who unfortunately
recently died from an Oam to lack a
wonderful writer called Eugen Weber.
Uh,
that put forward a view that some people
find a convincing in which I don't find
convincing at all. Um, but it is,
it became sort of the Canon or
the accepted assume truth about,
about national identity in France.
Was that a hit in his view until about
1880 until the republic became rooted,
uh,
that you had in a provincial France,
and particularly in rural France and
particularly in the south of France,
you had, um, a, almost a total
unawareness of, of, of what it was like,
uh, uh, uh, uh, French identity. Um,
somebody in about 1864,
if I remember right, uh,
went into a school and the lows as a,
which is the Frances least populated
department with only about 77,000 people
now live in the Lozier and ask them
what France was. Uh, and the, the,
the students in the, in the school,
I had absolutely no idea. Um,
and this particular book marshaled
all sorts of evidence about, uh,
if they're savage beliefs, it's even
put it that, that people believed in it.
It was just a superstitious,
uh, uh, isolated, uh,
rural France,
uh,
in which civilization
honored Vma or in quotes, uh,
could only come through,
um,
along with national identity through
these sort of agencies of change.
And this is what sociologists used
to call modernization theory, uh,
almost at its worst. And I say this would
be considerable affection for my, uh, uh,
late friend.
I Eugen Weber and we've debated,
had debated this before and the three
big agencies have changed some of what
you've already heard a little bit
about. Uh, according to Weber, uh,
that transform peasants into Frenchmen
were railroads. That is again,
the trunk lines reaching
out from Paris, um, uh,
all railroads leading eventually
to Paris. Um, secondly,
military conscription
teaching people, uh, you know,
brought tall, uh, or people
from a gas, can he or, or, uh,
even Leemoo Zap people
from the center of France,
a good French by males anyway,
by forcing them to speak
French and serve schools.
That is, uh, the increase in
literacy and France, a dramatic,
uh, in the course of the 19th century, uh,
there was always a big gap
between male literacy literacy.
And female literacy and this
gap is, is, is closed, uh,
such as by 1900. The vast majority
of people in France can, uh,
read, uh, and, and right. How do
we know that by the way? Well,
one of the ways that historians have tried
to assess those things in the past is
looking at military conscription
records. Uh, or for example,
looking at the people who are
witnesses to life's great ceremonies,
births,
marriages,
deaths where they can sign their name
or whether they just simply write an ex,
uh, that they can't,
that they can't sign. Um,
and of course there are other ways
of knowing this too, you know,
studying school records and this
sort of thing. So this is the,
the basic kind of interpretation
that became for many people, uh,
quite compelling, as I said the other
day. So by 1914, you have these what tall.
Uh, and you know, Britain is a language
has nothing to do with French at all. Uh,
being able to go off to die in
1914 or subsequent years, uh,
seeing than Masias.
Uh,
now the role of language in the
military is an interesting subject.
If you take the Austria Hungarian empire,
which had at least depending
on how you count it,
12 major national groups or nationalities,
uh,
to get anywhere in the army.
And the army was as a kind of social
promotion to become an officer,
you had to know German in order to become
a bureaucrat or to become a, you know,
a teacher in most parts of the or gear
and empire you need that you needed to
German. And so the argument has
been about Francis. Well, uh,
that's the traditional view is that
these, the school teachers, uh,
graduate Lou,
why there's her forcing the Virgin Mary
out of the walls of pub off the walls of
public schools,
replacing her with Marianne.
The female image of the republic are
also bringing French to all of the little
kids and therefore
civilizing France and uh,
turning French peasants into
French men and women or,
so that is a conventional view.
Well,
I don't agree with that view and I want
it. What I want to do is nuance it.
And then a drawing on some of the research
of my friend Joel Francois Shanae. Uh,
talk a little bit about
the role of schools, uh,
in the last half of the 19th century.
And then talk a little bit
about the roles of schools now,
because I said I find it interesting
now the whole question of, of,
of timing is essential
in, uh, in, in trying to,
to understand when we can at least,
and this may be sort of a leap of faith,
assume that a French national
identity had prim peer mediated,
all of the did thoughts mall in
France. And of course they could, is a,
is a case apart this even more
complicated. So the question is timing,
but again, simply to repeat
what I said the very first day,
if you look around the map of France,
what did people speak in 1871,
what do they speak in 1789? Uh, they
don't always speak those same things. Now,
in most cases they don't.
And so that's adjusted to the timing is
crucial in all of this. But just again,
I did this the other day, but
what the hell, let's do it again.
Up here in Flanders, uh, many, uh, spoke
Flemish. If you're moving into an Ohioan,
uh, amputated Lohan and, and,
and Alsace Wa, uh, most people,
the vast majority will be
more specific about this.
When we talk about the origins of
World War One spoke a German dialect.
It's very similar to that spoken in
Fribourg a savoir was a next in 1860.
They spoke a several, yeah.
Uh, language or dialect.
It's very much a like a Piedmontese.
Uh, uh, in the case of Italy, I mean,
language is fascinating at the time,
the unification of Italy at the time of
the unification of Italy and the 1860s
and seventies,
remembering that Medtronic once said
that Italy was a geographic expression,
the percentage of the Italian
population that it spoke.
Now what we consider to
be Italian was about 5%.
That is what people spoke Tuscan or
what they speak around around Florence.
So if you move down here and they spoke
Provence Sol, which is a real, you know,
written language and had a revival
with various poets, uh, you know, uh,
in the place called they bull a here,
which just turned into kind
of a equivalent of Disney's
sort of a tourist trap.
I like so many places in the south,
uh, moving into long door, long dope.
They spoke language of Auc, they spoke
Latin Dosha, uh, and we'll all the,
it's Patois, a variance spoken language,
variants and ovarian. They spoken in over.
Now Patois,
uh,
down here they spoke [inaudible] I
hear they spoke a patois influenced by
Spanish.
Here they spoke Bosc,
which has nothing to do with anything
outside of a little bit. Oh, Hungarian.
And finish up here. They
spoke, gas gone. Uh, and I,
I gave cases before, people speaking
Patois and even in Normandy and, and,
and even for that matter in, in the valley
of the war. And here they spoke. Uh,
we got tall. I, there's a wonderful book
if you want to, here's a good paper topic.
Uh, take a book called
the Horse of pride, uh,
written by a man called Ileus.
He wrote it in that tall,
it was translated into
French and then the English,
and it's about growing up in the 1920s
and thirties in, in Phinney staff,
which is the most, the furthest, most
Breton of all that it did pop them all.
And it's about what happens when, you
know, the, uh, the, the outsiders,
that is the French speaking to come and
they start calling the French Kodak,
hers because they come with Kodak Cameras.
And so they become the Kodak.
And so the church says,
you got it.
We have to stop all these crazy
superstitions in Brittany.
People rubbing statues to cure
themselves from various ailments. I mean,
the most ludicrous was probably a saint
imaginary saint called Saint Saint p sue
Sam piece too. So if you rubbed her,
said prayers to Sam [inaudible],
you probably already got it. You cured
yourself of urinary tract infections,
San P sue. So they send in these, these,
these priests who were supposed to
preach in, uh, in, in, in, in French,
in Brittany. This is the 1920s. So
again, the question of timing is crucial.
And at one point he tells us
hilarious story where the priest, uh,
I guess I can remember this when I
was a little tiny boy, uh, you know,
the priest would turn around and say,
at some point in the mass curiae Eleison
I guess that means Christ has mercy and
he would turn around and
all of these Breton's,
particularly all their Breton kids,
he turned around and say, curiae lace.
And then he,
he was greeted with gales of laughter
because Curiae Leyson means in Breck tall,
purely by coincidence
there are many wagons.
And then they would all laugh at him.
And so there was a failure
to understand each other. Uh,
and the idea that somehow
these breath tall,
we're all kind of plucks where
bumpkins were, were uneducated, uh, uh,
you know,
people who could never become part of
the true France because they didn't know
French very well. And of course, what the,
what tone do is they moved to Paris in,
in large numbers.
And the first thing you see in the garden,
we'll Parnoss Parnassus the assistance
still today. It's the social,
the office of social
assistance for Brett Tall. Uh,
and they all live around
the Gome Garmo Montparnasse,
which is why so many cafes around the
garment Parnass in Paris are named after
Bretton towns, although the, the
Samburu, uh, [inaudible], you know,
Dino and all that, all
this kind of stuff. Okay.
So what about timing and all
of this? So I mean, it is,
it was Weber completely wrong? No, I mean,
depends on what you're talking about.
If you wanted to talk about when people
in the [inaudible] begin thinking of
themselves as French,
uh,
the answer is really in the 17th
century or in the 18th century,
and certainly the French revolution,
which precipitates is enormous.
Civil war in the West was
basically a war between,
between a jackal band that has Paris
centralizing French and people speaking
Patois, who resisted, uh,
in the name of religion and in their
name of their nobles who resisted, uh,
the influence of the French state.
And if you're going to take, I mean,
Alsace and Lorraine
were conquered by Louis,
the 14th would have conquered
to Wyoming if he could have, uh,
and they become France in a French
in the 17th century. So there is,
there was a shared identity there.
You can have more than one identity.
You have more than one identity
in your lives yourself.
So it's kind of silly to look for this
one national identity that emerges if you
wanted to. Uh, one of the,
the, the historical facts,
it's bad news for this kind of
general oversimplified, uh, uh,
interpretation is a series of events that
doesn't concern you in this course. Um,
and that is the revolution of 1848.
There's a big revolution in 1848 it would
begins as an urban revolution in Paris.
And then Raul and, and limos and
Leone and all sorts of places, uh,
becomes basically a rural movement of
people on the left in this much of the
center. But, but on a much, even
more of the south of France.
And it ends in 1851 when, uh, Louis, uh,
when Louis Napoleon, the prince, uh,
who had guy who would become
a prince president who'll be,
will become Napoleon the third,
uh,
when he has a coup d'etat on
the 2nd of December, 1851. Um,
and people in Paris work wake up with
pill boxes. But what happens next,
and don't write this down,
but it's good to know,
is that it gives rise to the
largest national insurrection
in France in the 19th
century to defend the republic.
And most the secret societies that
were formed have a lot to do with this.
Um, I once read the interrogation
of great, great, great,
great uncle of our neighbor who had,
was arrested for trying
to defend the Republican.
His interrogation had to be translated
from Patois into French. And so,
uh, in departments I will go to the
mall, but from the periods OIM towel to,
to the Ode to, to the, to the
gap, the whole of the gap, uh,
the, the buzz ALP or now it's called the,
the, the, the provost, uh, the dog home,
the all dash and all these
places, uh, they rise up to
try to defend the republic.
And the vast majority of those people
that did were peasants and many of them do
not speak French.
Now,
political action is a form of
establishing one's own national identity.
They were fighting for a French republic.
One of the ironies is that people,
for example, in Catalonia, we're fighting,
we're fighting in Katella in the cats
that language for, for a jackal, Bam,
view a of the left held by the
left, that would, that would,
would view their own language as
something antithetical to progress of the
civilization that people thought was
represented by, by the French language.
So the, so the question of timing here,
you could argue that for this area here,
which was extremely backward,
do I hate that word? Uh,
the Leemoo Zap these departments here and
you don't have to know that it did pop
them all, but, but the,
the coaches the co has and the old van
or I used to live in, in the old VN,
I don't have much affection for it
actually, but, but, uh, that the,
that these areas,
the timing is much earlier than 1880s
and they didn't have to wait for trains.
I'm military conscription or even to be
able to know the French language visa vi
this school.
Um,
and so there's some more things that
it could be said also in terms of
explaining the, how complicated this
whole question of identity, uh, is.
Um,
and that we have a tendency,
people who believe in modernization
and everything has to pass through
modernization. You know, believe
that history runs on railroad tracks.
And all you have to know is when the
train arrives in the station and the,
that you forget people along the
way. A friend of mine once said, is,
it's bitter hard to write
the history of remainders.
That's something that has
always haunted me, that phrase,
people who weren't modern.
And therefore, you know,
aren't interesting and shouldn't
be studied. But in fact, uh,
the roads,
the,
the increase in roads in the 18th century,
the improvements in roads in the 18th
and the first half of the 19th century
were more important than railroads were
in achieving in many parts of France.
This kind of integration,
a peak. And furthermore,
if you look at the expansion of
the French economy, and again,
the only where we're thinking about is
timing, don't worry about these details,
just to having you think about
national identity. Um, it,
the French economy expanded rapidly in
the 1820s and thirties and forties and
again in the 1850s and sixties when
railroads at something to do with the 50s
and 60s. But it expands with
the improvement of, of, uh,
of roads that bring
people into towns that,
uh,
make them aware of the foss and make
them aware of politics and what these,
all these departments,
they're 18 of them that rose up
in 1851 that rural people before,
you know, as a drop there and run across
the fields and dumped their pitchforks.
And there were hunting rifles
as the troops come. But
you know, all of, you know,
all every one of these people,
you know,
what they really had in common was that,
that they,
they were in areas in which
the market had expanded, uh,
in the 1820s and the 1830s
through better roads.
So again, I mean,
railroads were important.
The first railroad ride that
many people took in France.
We're pilgrimage sites to
[inaudible] and things like that.
More about that another time.
But that's not all that's important.
And if you just look for what is modern,
that is like the Tj VA or the godawful
trains going to New York, uh, you know,
from here, uh, then you miss a lot of
the action. So the timing is important.
But what about, you know, 1914 did
these Breton's who were conscripted,
do they really,
really know much about France that they're
going off to fight for and to die for?
Well,
that's a leap of faith is as well.
Certainly it's true that the French
language spreads among breath tall,
uh,
through the war experience.
Those people lucky enough to have survive
there weren't in the 1,500,000 dead.
Uh,
but that's coming during the war is not
necessarily coming before the war at
all.
Furthermore,
just because one didn't speak
French, did that, you know,
condemn people to, to uh, you
know, eternal backwardness.
You know, I've studied strikes in
the motion 1905, and before that,
in which the workers who were striking
against big companies against Havilland
the porcelain, oh, that's another story.
The Havilland American porcelain company,
they were chanting long live. The
social republic, not in French,
but in Patois, but in Patois,
uh, in a was amp Antoine,
not in French. Does this mean they
don't, they're not French. No.
Doesn't mean that at all. It, but
it just means that the, you know,
part of their identity is being from that
particular part of France and you can
have multiple identities.
Uh,
and so the sort of simplistic view of
when these people start seeing themselves
as, as French is extraordinary
complicated. What about Corsica? You know,
you still got about seven or 8% of
the population. That's just a guess.
Who Don't want to be French at all.
You still a people blowing up.
Occasionally these, uh, you know, a high
rise apartments, condominiums, you know,
uh, in coursing, cause they don't
want tourists there, uh, in, uh,
in August. And, uh, you know,
to extent, I mean, you know,
I'm not for blowing up anything
but who can blame them,
not wanting tourists there in August. And
we were just blighted by, by tourists,
um, you know, uh, in the
south. Um, so I mean,
it just is terribly
complicated. And, and of course,
in the case of Brittany is
classic, um, you know, it's, uh,
gradually the French language
moves in this direction. Uh,
and,
but still in the 1920s and thirties,
the overwhelming percentage
of the population still
speak [inaudible] in daily
life. I mean, what about just an aside,
one of thousands of asides, but, but what,
you know, what about, what about
time since World War Two, uh,
before I get to schools, what
is, people speak, when do,
when does patois disappear?
Well,
I've always been interested in that
because we live in a village of about 339
people. Uh, the very old population,
the church bell rings
slowly, very, very often.
And another of us has been snatched away,
uh,
sadly in the south and this part of
France and the, and the owl dash in,
in what you call the viva. Hey, the
[inaudible], it doesn't matter. Um,
people spoke Patois in daily life.
I in,
uh,
the 1920s and 1930s,
and then people who were old, I
would speak at, among themselves,
uh, in the 1940s, 1950s. But
people that I know that are old,
including my boule
partner, you know, boom,
we played Wu and we direct a little
Sheldon a, aren't I supposed to say that?
But we did a little chardonnay on the
cider or posties calcap pasties to Tom on
Thong, uh, by the talks. I don't
want to have the autonomy, you know,
the pay people there. They're playing my
friend who was 80, uh, he could under,
he can understand Patois, but he can,
he can't read it and he can't write it.
When I asked him to correct,
uh,
some sentences that I
had copied in Patois, uh,
in a book that I did for the French
translation, he couldn't do it.
So that's disappeared. But say on, over
in, Oh, van, you, I mean, you know,
Varner or these departments here,
uh, w going to go through them all,
but have you all come towel
o'dwyer, you know, et Cetera.
Quita dome up here maybe will
be a, uh, a little bit in that,
in the 1960s and early 1970s,
Patois was still spoken
in many households.
And when the classic kind of eternal
triangle that is the parents,
the school kid and the
teacher was often then,
and it had something to do with language
because the parents felt themselves at
a disadvantage because they're French
wasn't as good as their patois.
This isn't the 1860s,
this is the 1960s. Um,
and in Corsica, you know,
there's still people to speak,
you know, a can, a language,
but basically almost everybody now speaks,
speaks French. And even in the movie,
I mentioned this the other
day, but you want enough, uh,
to flow hat and all of that. I mean,
there they had to equip the, the, the,
the main one of the main
actors, uh, uh, Daniel a toy.
They had to train him even though he's
from Avi know how to speak with a real
Provence style, uh, uh, accent.
But that, but that, but that,
that's false because in
the, in the, in the 1920s,
when he comes back from World War One,
uh,
they're going to be speaking or they're
going to be speaking a Provence saw.
They're not going to be speaking
French. Now what about, well,
I don't even have time to get into
this, but about universities, uh,
one of the things that's been good
in the last 20 years in France, uh,
is that before, I mean, as I said,
the goal wanted to crush regional
languages and cultures like grapes. Uh,
but one of the things has happened is
that now universities are very active in
teaching these languages that are part
of the regional identity that is not a
necessarily antithetical at all to
the sense of being French. I mean,
University of, of, of naught,
which is horribly right
wing. But then, uh, you know,
the event in particular
teaches, uh, uh, teachers, uh,
tall and there's been a revival.
There are Pepin y'all very,
very strong and Kathleen
last studies and to lose,
which is a very good university
there though, it's, uh,
the, the city is wonderful,
but the university has a dump. And also
when we had the big explosion there, uh,
that we were there when that all happened
in the fall of 2001 where, you know,
there were some even more
horrible explosions in this
country, as you well know.
Uh,
you know,
the whole campus was sort of moved by
this ignore a huge explosion when this
chemical factory, uh,
uh, blew up. But there,
there's been a revival in the
teaching of, of oxy town. Uh,
you know, these sort of lone
duck languages that were, uh,
soon to disappear, et
Cetera, et cetera. Now,
so be a little cautious in assuming that,
well,
everybody in 1914 felt themselves French
or thinking that these are agencies of
modernization are what,
what created this,
what we'd have to admit is, is a
strong French, uh, uh, French identity.
But also one of the things
I'm able to see, you know,
I'll probably be in tears by the end,
the lecture because I'm so
afraid that these regional
identities, uh, uh, you know,
are, are going to disappear and
that tourism may, may, uh, you know,
have something to do with that as well.
And that would be too bad with the end
of these license plates and things like
that. That, that, that I, I mentioned,
uh, uh, before, uh, that's not impossible.
Ironically, those of you, anyone
who's been to France or been anywhere,
I know that the Greek, the, the,
the green guid Mishnah in a
way that may have even had,
along with the gastronomy guides as a
way of at least making people think about
regional culture,
tying it closely to what is unique
about a region and presenting it to,
to tourists. And what's unique
about cuisine. Uh, and some of it,
none of them really famous. And now you
know, if you want to spend disown 12, uh,
saint [inaudible] for one person to eat
in these places is $250 per person. Uh,
some of them even a emphasize,
so emphasize their local
origins of what their,
uh, what they're preparing that this
may have. This may work against the,
this sort of onslaught of, of this, uh,
single, uh, French of culture. And so,
well, let this, all these flowers
continue to bloom. Now what about schools?
I mean, certainly Weber,
like anyone else's, right?
The schools make a huge difference.
And the history of,
of school houses is very interesting
now basically until 1833 until 1833.
And I'll explain why 1833 and a manner.
Um,
there are two things that
can be said about, uh,
the teaching of anything or three things.
One is that girls were,
were much likely less likely
to go to school. Uh, then, uh,
boys a second that many school
teachers were [inaudible], which were,
um, you know, mobile, the,
there are people who simply would go
from town to town teaching for a month or
two. Um, and that villages, uh,
some are very resourceful and we would
start schools taking advantage of one of
these people.
Uh,
but that the church education
was primarily dominated
by the Catholic Church,
uh, and education in the
informal sense as well. Now,
to be sure 5% of the French
population were Protestants.
More about that when we get to
the Dreyfus affair. Uh, but, uh,
the priest was often in
the 18th century, uh, uh,
the only person who could read in many
villages and his reading knowledge would
be basically limited to the
Bible or repeating things
that he'd been trained, uh,
to say. Uh, but the church and
the teaching sisters, the nuns,
uh, uh, really, uh,
dominate in many parts of France
and places that were practicing,
still practicing that old time religion,
dominant education.
Now in 1833 a law comes,
a law comes along called the Gisele La.
He's all was a protestant from neem. He
was not what the French would call real.
No, he was not. Uh, uh,
he was not a very happy go lucky guy is
you want to have a couple of beers with
are a couple of seven ups with
um, but he, and he was Protestant.
And so what he wanted to do was to rest
education away from the clutches of the
Catholic churches. He sought.
So through his inspiration,
they pass a law that says that
in every village in France,
in every one of Francis 36,000 communes,
you had to have a school.
Now the reality was that many were so
poor that they couldn't in our particular
village. And I'll have to make
reference to this cause I've, I've,
I've studied a little bit, you know, they,
the school moves from rented
place to rented place,
but 1833 matters because the school
teacher now has the stamp of official
authority. He is supposed to teach
in French. Now how do you know that?
When I say he has a stamp of official
authority, what does that mean?
So I got curious as to what that means
and to see what difference he made.
I did the following Wa, which is
that, as I said before, the, the,
the, the big rights of life, birth
bet. Well, baptism, marriage,
death have to be witnessed.
And since the French revolution, this is
kept by the state, not by the parishes.
So you have to have people who
witnessed it, who say, I see this baby,
I sign on the dotted line.
Now usually what you do in a small
village is you would take, uh,
some notable person who
knew how to read or write,
perhaps your rear wealthy uncle
or somebody wealthy uncle.
And then you'd cause a person who can
sign his name. And then you'd take, uh,
you know, your, your,
your cousin who may probably couldn't
sign his name but can make a pretty good
acts when push comes to shop with 1833,
I started looking at all
these registers, uh, you know,
just for a day that'll do it. But, uh,
I look at all the birth and all
the baptisms and all the day,
I mean all the Baptisms, all, all
the marriages and all the deaths.
And what happens is this proud
signature of the schoolteacher.
He becomes this sort of that obligatory
but the chosen person to say,
I have seen this baby.
I have seen this couple,
I have seen this corpse. And so,
and does that tell you something?
Was French school teachers still have this
wonderful signature that my kids were,
you know who right. Terribly of terrible
signatures like mine were never able to,
to pick up. But that tells
you something because he has,
he's supposed to get a
minimum salary of 200 francs,
which is virtually nothing because some
people are paying them an in asparaguses,
depending on, or are on end dives or an
apples are not pairing it with paying it.
All families that were too
poor were exonerated, uh,
from having to pay anything.
Uh, and he's just barely scraping
by, but he doesn't have a red,
white and blue sash like the mayor does.
But he represents the state
and the authority and above
all the prestige of the
state. And he's a challenge
in his very existence to,
uh, the Virgin Mary being on the wall, uh,
of these public schools.
These are public schools.
So now in 1850,
this is before the course,
it doesn't matter that there's
a law called the fall Lula,
which you can forget as soon as I
said it. Um, uh, and in the flu law,
a really,
it's a compromise with the church and,
and Louis Napoleon hands back control
over local committees to the church.
And in parts of France, which
people still, uh, you know,
still practice religion.
Religion still mattered in private and
public life to the Greta always had been,
you still have people that want to have
church schools and the north of France,
you know, when you're reading
Jeremy now you have to also map,
you've got these Belgian nuns
with these wild, you know,
hats that they used to have
still teaching in the schools.
You have convent people coming down the
ignore little literacy, not very much.
And they're teaching,
they're doing the best they can.
The quality of the clergy and France
was never higher than in, in the,
in the 18th century. It was pretty low
in the 19th century. But still, you know,
you have these competing sources
to educate the young people.
Dell parents often resist
their kids going to school.
Why would they want to do that?
Well,
mothers are responsible
for the household economy.
You have to have enough money
to keep the household going.
And for very many people and not
just workers and peasants. Uh,
it was difficult to explain
what difference in the long
run it mattered if their
child learned how to do more than the
very minimum of learning how to read and
write. So I got ahold of some
statistics on truancy for example.
And that was pretty interesting to see,
you know,
and it's quite clear that whenever
there was a harvest, uh, uh, soap,
warm harvest and much of
the southeast of France,
a wine harvest in champagne or,
or in burgundy are involved or are long
dork almost anywhere or the various
harvest, uh, you know, the beginning
July, usually with the grain,
I mean the kids just didn't go to school
because they weren't needed there.
But there's always this tension
because parents said, you know,
my little girl should be in say pay or
my little boy should it be in state pay,
which is the equivalent of first grade,
but I need her or I need him
to watch the small animals.
The big kids watched the big animals.
That's the way it is.
The big kids go on the trumps who malls.
That is when you take the sheep up
into the mountains. We still have,
we still have that every year.
We still,
my kids go on the tour or at least one
I'm going to have the transfer moss with
the sheep going up in the mountains
and they would say there's no way I'm
sending my kid to school. But in Francis
you'll read from chips, our wines book,
they put in laws as they do in Italy
as they do in Germany and as they do in
Britain that says you don't have any
choice but to Schwab you have to go to
school and you have to be there until
the age of 11 or the age of 12 so the
assumption is in this kind of view of
how this all works is that these guys,
these teachers, male teachers,
increasingly women teachers later,
but only later it becomes
a job along with the,
we'll talk about some other time along
with department store clerks and,
and when clerks becoming more
female as opposed to mail.
It becomes a way for peasant
girls and working class
girls or young women, uh, uh,
to get jobs.
But the view is that,
that these teachers who are called
as steeped in French assay to tour,
but just teachers,
these primary school teachers,
virtually nobody went to [inaudible].
It goes to high school.
Hardly anyone goes to
at least say, uh, uh,
until really until the second half of
the 19th century that these people are
teaching the French language and that
this is how you're going to learn it.
And there's always a story told
almost every place. How in school,
even during recess,
recreation recess,
the last person who says a word in Patois
has to clutch for the remainder of the
period.
Some oddly shaped rock or coin until
somebody else screws up and says,
award in Patois.
Are you kidding me?
That doesn't work like that at all.
And uh,
John Francois Shanay started,
he went out to study in the 18,
uh,
a 50s and 60s and 1870s
school teachers and schools.
And he begins with surveys,
some of which have I read that they
asked sexual teachers what you want for
yourself, what you want
for your village, uh,
for your school and what
do you want for your kids,
what you want for your kids. And they
would reply. But you know, these guys,
they're filling out forms that their
superiors in this hierarchical centralized
society are going to look at.
And if they write, you know,
basically they don't understand French.
We talk about the great battles of
Napoleon, but we do it in over and yeah,
you know, in Patois or we do an in
line dossiya or we do it in cat to La,
you know, then they're going to get
themselves in trouble. So you have to,
you have to sort of sneak around a little
bit these sources and the more Shanae
looked at these places,
it's clear that regional identity
is still very important. You know,
the famous map of France or the famous
map of the world that had in the 1890s
after the big period of new imperialism,
you're the color of France in its colonies
in Senegal. Or when that was Molly or,
or, or, or, or union or anywhere. Um,
but you have to begin with a region.
And so they're beginning with a region.
If they're from the alf it from
[inaudible] or from around won't pell Yay.
You know, that is their frame
of identity. And so it's,
it's absurd to think that they weren't
actually teaching in these languages,
uh,
local languages and dialects.
And patois justice is absurd to think
that people who didn't master French
perfectly or even very well at all didn't
have some, depending on the timing,
some sense of being French.
Uh,
so these schools are terribly important
and they could be teaching about,
you know, all of this stuff they
had to learn about, you know,
the kings of France and all this crap
that they still learn over and over again.
And you know,
they're teaching that stuff in Patois
and in dialect and maybe in the north of
France. I mean, you have to,
everybody's always talking about this
imaginary lines from some are low to
Jeanette here and is mostly in the south
of France where these languages, uh,
persist.
And I don't mean persist in a derogatory
sense where they continue to thrive,
but, but so, but this
bilingualism will, uh,
continue. Uh, and also, I mean a
lot of the lot of the views of,
of the sort of backward provinces are
written by regions or by military officers
for example,
who show up and they find some peasant
walking down the street and say, Hey, you,
you know,
can you give me this information?
And that the person understands
perfectly well what they want,
but they identify some person coming with
speaking French is a tax collector or
a military guy or something like that.
And your APP,
just to give that secret smile and
pretend like you don't understand a damn
thing just to secret smile and then
they go back then and right. Boy,
I've never done people here. They can't
speak French at all. They are hopeless.
They are out of date. They are
prueck, they are, you know,
bumpkins and all of that.
Uh,
so,
but I mean eventually as I said that you
have these school houses that they will
improve over time. They
get more resources. They're
made to have more resources.
Uh, the towns do more and more for
them. A girl's school start up, uh,
uh, a girls' education increases rapidly.
And thus it's quite, you know, these,
if you're another Zola, a novel,
which is a great one called Obama. Oh,
Buena I did dom,
which is about department stores,
about the departments are
Beaumarchais in Paris. I mean,
for these young women get
really miserable jobs.
And what they're doing is
they're, they're, you know,
they're sleeping in dormitories and under
horrible sort of draconian regulations
about what they can do.
But for them to get those kinds of jobs,
they have to be able to count.
They have to be able to read,
they have to be able to write. And so,
uh, women's education increases, uh,
dramatically, uh, during this
whole time. Uh, and, but, but what,
what does not,
you know,
it does not change is the prestige
that the school teachers have that they
maintained as, as representing
not only national identity,
but also regional possibilities.
Uh,
and in teaching the youth of France,
how to,
uh, how to, uh, read and write. Um, no,
I thought just because, you
know, maybe it might be,
you'll find it interesting for the last
10 minutes since I did what I basically
wanted to do and held myself down and
not given countless and countless of
examples is talk a little bit about now,
uh,
because one of the things that I
became interested in is how, you know,
if these areas in the south
particularly that are tourist infested,
uh, during the year, if
they are going to remain,
remain more than simply sites
for tourists from the north,
from Belgium and from Germany and from,
uh,
the Netherlands and literally from the
north of France to come and visit schools
have to maintain their traditional role
in representing the identity of these
communities.
And those of you who are,
if there any people here from Nebraska
where my wife is from a or from Idaho or
from Oregon,
where I'm from,
from eastern Oregon or from
Wyoming and places like that,
we'll know the process by which
schools are closing down, uh,
because they're not enough kids left.
France had in 1939, uh, excuse me,
an 1851,
two thirds of the departments in France
in 1851 were larger than they were in
1939 because of two things.
One,
the collapsing birth rate,
which I will talk about
another time in much of France,
people stop having babies Twan period.
Or they'll have,
you know, 2.1 babies or 1.8 babies.
That's kind of hard, but you know,
in the statistically and second is that
what in French a gone they buy or the
big departure starts as people who
have lost access to common resources,
for example,
in the mountains or the silk industry
collapse or the wine industry co collapses
more about that. When I talk
about flocks, red disease,
don't write that down or even tried to
spell it now. Um, there's this huge,
uh,
withdrawal from the countryside toward
more urbanized departments and because
the population has stopped growing,
uh, basically by the, by 1900,
if it wasn't for the arrival of,
of people from Italy and
other places and from Spain,
the French population wouldn't
even, uh, uh, reproduce itself.
It wouldn't even stay, stay constant. Um,
in much of France. And indeed, uh,
I would argue of 36,000 communes.
Uh,
let me say that perhaps in 10 or
12,000 Commons after World War Two,
there were one room, school houses
and a one room school house. You know,
you've seen movies involving them.
They have them in the United States too.
In a one room school house,
you'll have all the kids have all the
grades being taught by one person.
Our kids for several years in a one room
school house is a great way to grow up.
You have in France, you have grades
from first through fifth grade.
They're calling to say, say why, you
know, et cetera. And the oldest kids,
if the kid,
if he's he or she is remotely intelligent,
will help with the younger ones. Uh, but
everybody's together in the same school.
And with the depopulation population,
what they did is they tried
to have single sex schools.
You have a boys' school
and a girls school,
but that becomes too expensive because
the state is paying for all this, uh,
and the communes are paying part of
it. So what they do is they say, okay,
we're going to have one school, it's
called in French, a class unique.
And it's a wonderful way to
grow up, uh, in, you know,
where you've got cats and you have
dogs and you have a, you know,
the older kids are trying to get ready
for their exams, uh, you know, uh,
where they don't have any
more, but we'll have a, uh,
to show that their certificate that
they have been in class through, uh,
your are equivalent here in America of
the fifth grade. And you might have,
if they have a kindergarten,
you might have a little boy or girl
painting in the corner. Literally, uh,
while all this other stuff is going
on. And you know, in our class,
a dog gave birth during the middle of
mass, uh, in, in, in our class, in,
in the, in the, in this school.
And all of the tests that people have
have had showed that kids with who come
out of that environment do just as well.
In fact,
even a little better then
people in your normal class,
we've got everybody in the
first grade there, they all are.
And here's the second grade.
And then you've got sort of elite class
for those people who have parents are
pushing enough to get them in that,
you know,
and you've got all that stuff
and some of what you've seen.
But what as all of this is expensive?
What's happened over time is that these
one room school houses are closing down
and between 1975 about and about night,
let's say 1990 10,001 room
school houses in France closed.
And what this does is it causes
unemployment for school teachers.
But many of them, you know, I
can stay on in other capacities,
but it means that they're long bus rides.
Uh,
they're already long bus rides because
many depart, they pop them all,
don't have that many high schools.
And you've got to take buses in
order to get to the high schools.
And that sort of thing.
And you know, and, and,
and that is sad because that's a
wonderful way to uh, grow up, uh, in,
in, in these schools. And that's part of,
of regional identity and village
identity that's going to disappear.
And let me give you an example again
from our village cause it's interesting.
We were faced with uh, uh, with uh, the
fact that the school was going to be,
uh, either grouped with another
village, detested, rival, uh,
or be shut down.
So what do our kids are supposed to do?
Where are they supposed
to go to school? And, um,
one day we were convoked
to the town hall to the Ma.
He by our school teacher and
our, most of our parents, uh,
meetings with the school teacher
ended with a bottle of ARMAGNAC.
I'm pleased to say,
and we're all dear friends,
even the people that you're not your
friends with, you got along with fine.
But remember what I said
about the role of the school.
The school represented from the,
the outside France looking into the
village in principal teaching French,
providing opportunities for people
to get educated and get a school,
get a job in the post office or the
train station or in a department store in
Paris avenue to lose or wherever.
And one day we were Convult by the mayor
and the mayor then wasn't a friend of
ours is somebody we knew and
he had a sash on and he said,
Woo instead of two,
you know,
he spoke to us formally and this teacher
was nervous. He said, God, he said,
we have the great pleasure, hey and a
man and we're all looking at it and say,
wow, you know, kids go, you know
Mr of the mayor is going to hear,
he's going to be here to talk
to us and we're all nervous.
Get quote where our school
is maybe going to close down.
We'd started a semi illegal canteen to
feed the kids lunch room so the parents
wouldn't put their kids
in the other school.
At one point we only had
nine kids left in the school.
We can get close down and were a little
nervous and the, and the guy says, uh,
my friends, which he's
not a, we're not, he said,
we're gathered here together so that we
can best see how we can cheat the state.
And the minute he said, cheat the
state, we had an alliance, all of us,
because how are we going to keep us some
illegal lunchroom going so that we can
keep a couple more little kids in our
school? How are we going to do that?
And I realized then that the
relationship had totally changed,
that the school still represents France.
It's a cruel system where you'll be in
the fourth grade and their teachers will
call your parents and say,
you know,
votes with fee at a noon that happened
to one of my daughter's friends,
your daughter,
she's nothing.
She has to go off and do this menial job
because she's never going to make it to
the next level. There's always tension.
There's parents meetings. I mean,
it's a cruel system, but, but
it was the outside looking in,
it represented the possibilities
of France and the French language,
which we've already exists.
We've exaggerated.
And I suddenly realized that now it's
very different. And then if our village,
it's like all of these other villages
are good to remain living v Wall and more
than just a,
a Michelin Infuse Spec on the dot where
people will come along with their,
their, their green guides.
Because it's so beautiful.
And this is true of all of these places.
They're not all equally beautiful that
our school has to survive because even
people whose families have hated each
other's guts for generations who detest
each other,
all agree that since the church is
now just a voluntary association,
like any other, like the, like the, you
know, the podunk club, the boom club, uh,
or the food club soccer club,
uh,
that the only thing that arguably will
hold the village together is the identity
that comes to this school,
the school of this particular village,
which is called Bazooka.
So just simply in conclusion,
you know, let's not exaggerate
this one national identity,
nor assume that modernization has
come crashing along. Let us realize,
realize that complexity of
national and regional identities,
which can become intertwined,
which are intertwined,
and let us realize that these schools
have a remarkable role still in these
communities.
It terribly important
at the most basic level,
and that remains in France
neighborhood and village.
See you on Wednesday.